[Music]
it's already been three years since
miles morales saved brooklyn back then
spider-man into the spider-verse was the
first movie to successfully bring the
concept of the various marvel universes
to the big screen since then every fan
has been looking forward to a sequel
centered around the various neighborhood
spideys we can reassure you we won't
need to wait for ages
based on current information spider-man
into the spider-verse 2 is scheduled to
hit theaters in october 2022
in order to make the time a little more
bearable until then we have already
taken a look at some possible storylines
we will introduce them to you in this
video we hope you enjoy it
considering that the first part had a
lot to offer and that it's been a while
we'll briefly summarize the most
important points
if you haven't seen it yet and don't
want any spoilers
you should hurry up and skip to the next
part
young miles morales was bitten by a
radioactive spider
this happens in the same brooklyn where
peter parker from the famous spiderman
movies of 2002 fights evil as the
friendly neighborhood spider
when he suddenly acquires abilities he
returns to the place where he was bitten
there he finds spider-man fighting
kingpin among other villains
the gangster boss opens a portal to
other universes trying to get his dead
family back
but fails in doing so
nevertheless he manages to kill peter as
new york mourns and mild stands at
peter's grave an older version of peter
unexpectedly shows up
shortly after spider-gwen spider-man 1
and spider-ham also
it quickly turns out that all the
spideys were dragged into this universe
from other ones by kingpin's machine
in spite of all warnings the gangster
boss wants to switch on the machine
again which would lead to the
destruction of the whole city
in the final battle the spider-man
succeed in defeating kingpin and his
gang of villains united
everyone returns to the universes and
miles morales becomes the new friendly
neighborhood spider in new york
so what sort of multiverse spider-man
will we meet in the sequel thanks to the
post-credits scene and some interviews
with the producers we already know a
little bit of information about this
body so we'll provide a law order in the
upcoming movie as expected miles morales
remains the protagonist of the film the
young teenager eventually became the new
spider-man of the city after his victory
over a kingpin
besides we are all curious to see how
the relationship with his father will
evolve after they finally managed to get
together at the end of the last film
as has already been confirmed gwen stacy
will also be back after all spider-gwen
ended up befriending miles and it's
clearly hard for her to say her goodbyes
and return to her universe
gwen gets female support from jessica
drew who most of you probably know as
spider woman as a young girl she was
seriously ill prompting her father to
develop the spider serum to cure her
however
upon injecting it into her she developed
superpowers similar to miles morales
just like him she can also send out an
electric shock also known as a venom
blast
in the comics she first joined hydra
before joining shield whether that will
also be the case and into the spider
verse 2 is yet unclear
we were already introduced to a newcomer
of the second part in the post-credits
scene of the first movie then we see
miguel o'hara also known as spider-man
2099
said spider-man as you can guess is from
the year 2099 where the world is ruled
by corporations and the time of heroes
is long gone o'hara tries to become
spider-man through the use of genetic
manipulation which he ultimately
succeeds in doing unlike his
predecessors he no longer needs web
shooters as he can shoot threats himself
however
he lacks the spider sense that the
others have in return he is able to
paralyze his opponents by biting them
another newcomer is takuyaya mashiro
also known as the japanese spider-man
sure we already had an anime or manga
spidey in the first movie
nevertheless tequila will be based more
on the original the tokyo boy is an
enthusiastic motocross racer until he's
injected with the serum that alters his
genes similar to miguel o'hara
his powers are comparable to those of
peter parker the only real difference is
that his great weakness is the extreme
cold similar to that of real spiders
whether peter b parker will be returning
is not yet certain
at the end of the first part he gets
back to his universe like all the others
and manages to approach mary jane and
new as a result of what he has
experienced thus his life seems to have
a purpose again
in an interview voice actor jake johnson
said that it would break his heart if
you were not allowed to play the role of
the down and out spidey version again
therefore not everything appears to be
cut and dry just yet nothing is known
about potential antagonists so far which
of course leaves plenty of space for
creativity when it comes to the plot of
the second part
fortunately there are already a few
clues regarding the plot so we don't
have to completely speculate here what
will be clear is that there will be a
love affair between miles and gwen this
was already planned to happen in the
first part but then was cut out in
addition spider woman's appearance will
also introduce the plant spinoff this
one supposed to be about gwen stacy
jessica drew and cindy moon also called
silk nothing more is known for sure at
this point
diving into the eventual plot let's
briefly talk about the post-credits
scene once more
there a jump is made into the universe
of miguel o'hara you see a researcher
talking about how the multiverse almost
collapsed but only nearly after all
the woman hands spidey bracelet that can
be used to jump purposefully through the
multiverse this is how miguel heads to
1967 to bring the famous comic book and
meme spider-man into his reality
the end
it's conceivable that spider-man might
need help in his own universe in 2099 as
he cannot cope with a villain there on
his own the film will therefore not be
said in the new york we know but in that
of the future
there the city is divided into two
districts the upper one for the rich
elite and the lower one
superheroes do not actually matter
anymore and are only reminiscent of
stories from brighter days
if everything goes smoothly spider-man
2099 will have the support of at least
three more heroes in fact four if we
take peter b parker into account
possible antagonists can already be
deduced from the comics in them o'hara
usually finds doctor doom or venom since
venom is just getting a second
installment we can very well envision
doctor doom here kingpin's attempt to
mess around with a multiverse could lead
dr doom to develop his own plans to use
the power of different universes for
himself
this would definitely make him one of
the most dangerous opponents for even
without his power he is one of the most
powerful villains
in any case traveling between universes
will probably play a big role perhaps
this will allow to stay longer in
another universe which would no doubt
benefit the romance between miles and
gwen
but of course that's just our theory and
it's not confirmed in any way
those were our facts and theories about
spider-man into the spider-verse 2. what
are your thoughts do you have any ideas
on what the film could look like
let us know in the comments otherwise
all we can do is wait for the first
trailer to come out the movie is
expected to be released in theaters on
october 7th 2022 we're definitely
looking forward to learning more about
miles morales and this spider-verse see
you next time
[Music]
you